[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I'm excited to have
Priyanka Vergadia, a customer
engineer at Google
Cloud, here with me
to show us how to
set up service level
monitoring in Stackdriver.
Hi, Priyanka.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Hi, Stephanie.
Thank you for having me.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Google has published
our practices
for managing reliable
services at scale and site
reliability engineering
books and this SRE workbook.
One of the main
principles of SRE
is using service
level objectives.
Can you show us how
developers can do the same?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
Let's dive right in and let
me show it through a demo.
SPEAKER: OK, great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Perfect.
So I have this website here that
is built to order some stuff.
And so I'm going to put
something in the cart.
It's an e-commerce website,
so it lets you order things,
and then it places an order.
So I have my credit card
information in there,
and we just placed an order.
Now, behind the scenes,
there is a lot going on
in this particular application.
So if you look at
what's going on here,
this is the service
architecture of the application.
And it has a front end.
It has various
different services
talking to the front
end-- the check out,
the catalog, the product
catalog, the card service.
There's a lot that's
going on here.
And if you see further,
they're pretty much all
written in very different
languages as well.
So there's a lot of
complexity behind the scenes
that's going on.
And this is all done through
microservices, as you can see.
So it's important to understand
that a simple website can
be set up with different
services in the back end
and have different
languages that it can be
written in-- so complexities.
SPEAKER: Right.
And microservice
architectures mean
the app itself is broken
into many small pieces.
And doesn't that make
it hard to understand
how all the pieces
fit together and where
to start investigating
when there is a problem?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: It becomes
very hard for the operations
team, especially in
microservices architecture,
to figure out what's going
on, which services is up,
down, talking to each other.
So there's a good tool in
Stackdriver Monitoring called
Topology, where you
can actually look
at the topology of your
different microservices
talking to each other.
So I have it open here, and when
you open the service topology,
I can look at a specific
service that I'm interested in,
and then see which other
services it is talking to.
So it gives me a view.
I can click on one, and it gives
me a view of what's going on
and which services
it is talking to,
which is pretty
helpful when you're
working in an
environment that has
so many different microservices
that it's talking to.
SPEAKER: Wow, and
this is great because,
with microservice-based
apps, you can clearly
see the inter-service
dependencies
and use that to double-check
new code rollouts.
But let's say you're
setting up alerts.
Ops staff can burn
out a lot of the times
from getting notified of all the
potential causes of a problem,
making it hard to align SREs
with customer interests.
How can we identify which
behaviors really actually
matter for that service
during service degradation?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So there is also another tool
within Stackdriver Monitoring
for services, where you can
actually set up SLOs and define
your SLOs for the services so
operations does not actually
get affected by just looking at
all the different alerts that
can come by.
It's actually a practice
within our SRE teams,
where we make sure that our
SRE staff is only monitoring
alerts that are related to
customer issues and front end
customer related issues and not
every single issue that might
be a cause to those issues.
So let's see that
in the demo as well.
SPEAKER: Great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So if we click on Services here
in the Stackdriver Monitoring,
let's look at front end.
And when we go do that, you're
able to see the service level
optimization.
So let me click on SLOs.
And in SLOs, you obviously
see nothing here.
So we're going to
set one up and say,
we want to set up
for availability,
and then we can do it
rolling or calendar.
I want to say, in the
month, if we reach 99%,
or low availability, then
I want to get alerted.
That's a good way of
saying that you're not
going to be alerted
for everything
but you still want to be alerted
for when we go less than 99%.
And then you can also
set up a latency alert.
So in this case,
if we say latency--
and I may want to
set up differently
for different services.
For the front end,
you could say,
my pages should load in less
than 1,000 milliseconds,
otherwise I want to be notified.
And in this case, also,
let's say it's 90% our goal,
and then we submit that.
So these are the two
alerts that we just set up
for latency and availability.
And they are not just
thresholds because we
are saying this percentile.
So it's not going to
be chatty and noisy.
It's going to be,
if this happens,
then we really want to get
notified because the service is
not working fine.
So that's a good way of
identifying, making sure
that you're not burning
out your operations staff.
SPEAKER: Excellent.
How do you follow these best
practices given the resources
that you have?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So you also have metrics
and diagnostics in there.
So if you click
on Metrics, you're
able to see the request counts
and the response latencies,
which will guide you through
the request and response.
And if you click on
Diagnostics, that actually
takes you to the Trace.
So now, if I want
to drill deeper
into the 95th percentile,
which is probably
the one I want to look at
because it's not performing
very well, then I
can click on that
and see a specific request, why
it was slow, for what reasons,
and which requests
were actually slow.
So in this case, we can see
that the checkout service was
a little bit slow
in send and receive,
so we may want to
delve deeper into that
and find out what's
going on there.
So the Diagnostics tab
and the Metrics tab
are really good friends
for troubleshooting.
SPEAKER: Great.
And, at some point,
you probably need
to dig a little deeper
into the services signals.
Let's say, maybe you
received an SLO alert
and there's no obvious
upstream cause,
or you have a customer complaint
outside of an SLO alert
that you need to
investigate, or maybe you
need to see how the new rollout
of your code version is going.
How do you get a coherent
display of all the signals
for a specific service?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah,
so I think the best
thing to do at that point is--
you got an alert through SLO.
You want to look at
metrics and diagnostics
to kind of figure
out what's going on
because metrics and
diagnostics are going
to be helpful to understand
which specific service is not
performing well.
As you can see in diagnostics,
when we drilled deeper
into a specific service,
we were able to find out
that checkout is the culprit.
And so we can drill
deeper into that.
So those metrics and diagnostics
would be your great friends
in order to find out
what's actually going on.
SPEAKER: So Stackdriver
service monitoring
gives you a whole new way
to view your application
architecture, reason about
its customer-facing behaviors,
and get to the root of
any problem that arises.
So thank you so much,
Priyanka, for showing us
how Google is transforming the
ops experience of cloud native
and microservice deployments.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Thank you for having me.
It was fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]